- Are you into musicals?
- I am. Well, I, yeah, I
grew up, um, a big dancer.
And so I feel like we had
chorus line, all the things,
but when your producers asked
me, my girlfriends and I
were talking about it this
weekend, the greatest showman,
and I know I love your rendition.
- Oh, the re-imagined. Yes. Yes. Yes.
- Oh yeah. So good.
- Oh my gosh. It's just,
it's an honor to do something like that.
- It's so good.
- Because I'm not able to do Broadway.
So it's like kind of a cool
way for me to get to do it.
- Yeah.
- But did you see, did you see Bridgerton?
- Okay. I gotta be honest.
That was one I didn't see. And
after, I mean, episode five,
apparently is all I need
to see listening to you.
- Here's the thing. Just,
skip to episode five.
- Really? Now, is this
something you watch by yourself,
or you watch with your girlfriends.
- This is something I watched by myself.
- Okay.
- You can do you. No,
No. I did hear that you were
recently diagnosed with something.
- Oh, God! Kelly!
- Wait, it's called high return syndrome.
- Yeah. It has nothing to
do with Bridgerton, at all.
- Okay.
- It's like high risk
return syndrome. Okay.
Online shopping. Don't know
if you have time for it.
- That's all I have time.
- Okay. But, like clothes shopping, right?
Ladies. We have doing it?
- Yeah
- Okay. Here's the
thing. I order two sizes,
Cause I don't know how my
ass is going to fit in a pair
You know what I mean?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So I get the large, I get the
small, I get all the things.
- I do that all the time. Yeah.
- Right? All the shirts. I
do a small, I do a medium,
I don't know. Well, so then
you've got to return it all,
which I'm proud that I
do because half the time,
I just want to leave
it in my closet. Well,
Well, I went to go return
something the other day
and I get it. It's not big time problems
compared to what a lot of
people are dealing with,
but they forgot the shipping label.
So I just called the lady and
at the company and I said,
"Hey, y'all forgot the shipping label.
Um I just wanted to see if I
could get it emailed so I could
send it on." And they were
like, "well, actually ma'am,
we're not sending you shipping
labels anymore. You've been,
we're calling you a high risk returner."
And I was like, I don't feel contagious.
I mean, we've been tested so much.
They're punishing and judging me,
for returning all the
stuff that doesn't fit.
And I actually feel
really, like, offended.
- I know. Here's the thing.
I know a lot of people that
do that because if you can't,
especially this past two
years, nobody wants to go out.
Really.
- No.
- So a lot of people do that.
- Why are you labeling me?
- Cause you don't know.
Why? Get off of me!
- It's just. Give me the
label and stop labeling me.
- They just made an
entire syndrome for you.
- It's so rude, and contagious. Who knew?
- So, what's up with your clothing line?
You're now going to NHL, right?
- Yeah. Well, I just have to say
it's kind of an emotional moment,
cause we started it three years
ago and you were nice enough
to have me on like right
when I kicked it off.
- I still have it. You gave me stuff.
- I know. And we have bigger
and better and more selection.
We have the NFL NCAA college
NBA, and now we um get the NHL,
which is really cool because
it's kind of myself and um my
creative director and designer of it all.
She, uh, her husband played
in the NHL. My husband did.
So it's kind of like we're coming home.
- I have been to more
hockey games than any sport
- Oh you have?
- because of Nashville. I lived
there for like 12, 13 years.
And I've been to so many Pred games.
- Oh my gosh. Well, I'll
send you Pred stuff.
Or whoever you want
- I'm just saying, I'm just like, I'm d,
I love a sports ball
time. I love it, yeah.
- You love hockey cause
it's a lot of beer.
- I like hockey, and I, they
slam into each other. Yeah
- Yeah. So much fun.
- Yeah. Okay. Wait, you're
around, um athletes a lot.
- Yeah
- So many of them have
pregame rituals. Right?
- Yeah
- So what do you do
before you hit the field?
Like for interviews? What do you do?
- So, what I do before I hit the field,
I always call my dad, because my d
- I love this about you.
- Oh I know, I love that. Thank you.
Yeah. He's my best friend.
And he knows so much about
sports and like he's the one
that got me interested in it
used to tell me all the
stories all the time
about the athletes and
coaches, all the things.
- Yeah
- And then I listened to
really dirty rap music,
really explicit.
- Like Gwyneth Paltrow.
She was on here and
asked her favorite song.
And she said WAP.
- Yeah. Or Up. Um, no but
I love like the pre pregame
before the fans come in and
the guys are just warming up
when they're FaceTiming their families
and all the things. They
like to put on their music.
And so I'm always like going
to talk to somebody I'm like,
hold on, let me, Shazam this like, Ooh,
this is dirty and fun. And what.
- I love. Wait, who's like
your favorite to listen to?
- Um. I don't know anyone.
Who's just like real, I mean
- I like Kendrick Lamar.
- Yeah so do I. So do
I. Cardi B's fantastic.
I'll never know all
the words. Nicki Minaj.
- Never
- Fantastic. Just the
fact that they, you know,
all the beats and everything. And I,
I think I'm so cool when I listen to it,
I pretend I'm a football player. So.
- Oh my God. I pretend I'm them
like while they're singing. Cause I,
it takes all of, it takes
God, Jesus, the holy spirit,
everything to keep me on a treadmill.
And also, also rap music.
No, I just used to love it.
And now I don't and I'm
just like, oh my God,
there's so many things I'd
rather be doing right now,
- I know
- but okay cool for my
heart, whatever. But like,
so I do it and I listen to
a lot of Kendrick and Cardi.
They're, they're, they're
good to listen to,
- So good. So good.
- but I feel bad ass.
I have to feel bad ass.
- That's what I'm saying that.
And I like to feel that
way before I go, you know,
in front of the camera to do a game.
And I also, to make me feel like a kid,
I eat like one of those Uncrustables,
like a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich, because.
- I've heard this about you, actually.
- Yeah
- you take kids snack food
for your food. It's awesome.
- Well think about it. Down on the field,
I don't have much time,
cause I'm running in
after a coach or I'm
running out with a coach.
I can't, I, it's, I
used to back in the day,
I'll crush a hot dog or chicken
fingers or all the things,
but I don't have time.
Uncrustables are so easy.
They come in that plastic wrap
and you can just eat it so fast.
- Yes
- And what's better than a PB and J
when you're standing there for
seven hours and you need a,
like something to eat?
- Yeah. Something yes. Well,
I heard this about you.
So I stole some food from my son's lunch.
I brought you a prize.
- What flavor? Do you know?
- It's a secret. It's a surprise.
- You just have the best
snacks when you come here.
You wanna know something
else that I love about you?
There's toothbrush and
toothpaste and mouthwash
in the bathrooms here, at
the Kelly Clarkson show.
- Here's the thing.
- And I appreciate that.
There is nothing more
than I have a phobia of then in your nose
- You're coming on TV. Yeah
- or bad breath.
- Yes
- And yeah, that I, I always
would do the Listerine tabs,
which why they haven't given
me a deal really is annoying.
I did, I did a whole thing
one time where I like shoved,
it was really fast.
This guy hit a knockout
or walk off home run. I grabbed it.
I put a ton in my mouth and
then I went to talk to him and
he started crying and I
literally said, "oh my God,
are you emotional?" And he
goes, "Your breath is so fresh.
It's hurting my eyes." And
I was like, "Thank you"
- Oh my God.
- Yes
- That's awesome.
- Right? So I appreciated the toothpaste.
- You should've said it's
better than halitosis.
So, you're welcome.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- So wait, how are you with
cooking your own meals?
Cause you said you have to
snack real quick on the field.
So how are you with like, coo-
- Horrible
- oh, me too.
- Yeah. I live out of a suitcase
during the football season
and I try really, really hard
for my husband and myself
to be good at it, but I suck.
- Yeah
- I'm just so bad. It's embarrassing.
- I can be good. It just
takes me three hours
in what should take someone
30 minutes to do, generally.
- I have a girlfriend and she
is so good with her recipes
and everything. I am. So by the book,
like I have to be like, okay, a quarter,
- see, you're a good baker, then.
- No, but I'm not. I'm not
good at any of it. Like, I'm
- Baking is like precise.
Cooking is like, I don't
know, a dash of this and a
- That's my girlfriend,
Jackie. A dash, a sprinkle
What does that mean? I don't
even know what that means.
- What does that mean? It's relative.
- Yes, exactly.
I went in open.